let's get to unemployment we have a
situation right now where to stop the
virus from spreading to stop the
invisible scourge or scourge it's Trump
calls it from spreading notice by the
way Trump has not mentioned the Chinese
virus in his last three press
conferences clearly somebody got to him
but now the invisible enemy the
invisible scourge is what he says we
need people to stay home that's the
point for some people this merely means
you work from home and not much changes
for others for many people this means
their employer is closing down they no
longer have a job or at least they don't
have one until things open back up which
Donald Trump wants to apparently start
doing around Easter time he wants the
church is packed for Easter we now have
a report about the number of new
unemployment claims this past week and
the number is three million three
million two hundred and eighty three
thousand this is a staggering number
when you look at new claims per week
going all the way back to the mid 1960s
it is a stunning number now to give you
some context the expected new claims for
last week we get the numbers the week
after so that's why we're looking at
last week this week could be even worse
expected new claims last week were 1.6
million that's what we were expecting
economists actual claims came in at just
under 3.3 million
actual claims doubling the expected new
claims and for reference the previous
record for new claims in a week was in
1982 when there were six hundred and
ninety five thousand new claims now of
course you've got to adjust for
population growth in the United States
but still a crooked number to take a
baseball phrase of course all these
numbers from the US Department of Labor
so this was last week now since the
reporting is on a delay this week's
numbers will come in next week this
week's numbers could be even worse
because we've seen more states start to
shut down and we could see potentially
even worse numbers next week
now if you're looking for anything
anything anything at all to mitigate the
obvious absolute and total disaster of
these numbers there is one thing that I
will say and this does not this is just
a reality a lot of these jobs aren't
truly jobs that are over these are
furloughs these are sort of like leaves
of absence and when these businesses can
get going again and not all of them will
a lot of these jobs are very quickly
going to come off of the unemployment
numbers how soon that could be we don't
know and of course the longer this goes
some businesses aren't going to be able
to make it through restaurants are a
tragic example imagine a restaurant in a
city with a $5,000 a month rent payment
which is not not unusual for restaurants
in a city imagine they have you know 15
employees on a regular basis basis
including a lot of waitstaff right now
for example in Massachusetts they're
doing takeout only there maybe down from
15 employees to three employees just
people cooking and the owner is you know
handling orders because their state has
a stay-at-home order their revenue is
drastically reduced after they pay their
three employees and they pay their rent
and their utilities they may still be
losing money if they don't get rent
support if there aren't rent deferrals
at a certain point maybe they can do it
for a month maybe they can do it for two
months because they want to keep their
business they'll go out of their pocket
to keep it running on a take out only
basis but eventually you're gonna see
these business owners start to just walk
away and that's why we've got a grin and
bear it now together at the same time if
20 states do stuff now and then five
stop and six more start next week it'll
it's not going to work okay if half the
country does nothing we're just going to
extend this and it's going to be longer
and longer it might be less bad in
individual spots for a little while
until it's not we're starting to see
Louisiana become a hot spot we're
starting to see places now ramp up the
cases the real path is and what Trump
should say if if Trump again if Trump is
determined to say he wants to reopen on
Easter which is crazy Trump should say I
want to reopen on Easter but I need all
50 governors I need every state
to stay home shut down all non-essential
businesses takeout and delivery only at
restaurants canceled on necessary
medical appointments no schooling etc
etc Trump should say I need that for the
next 17 days if you want me to be able
to reopen partially you know maybe young
people in some states I don't know if
he's determined to do it say you need
all 50 states to do the damn thing
because otherwise it's not going to
happen otherwise this is going to extend
and the numbers are going to go up and
up and up that's what's happening and
we're gonna go look at those numbers a
little bit later make sure you're
following the David Pakman show on
Instagram for continued coverage and
funny pictures to add a little levity at
David Pakman show on Instagram while
you're there follow me at David Pakman I
want to give a quick shout out to one of
our sponsors VIN Charo watches they're
giving my audience 15% off your entire
order when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch maybe you don't usually wear
a watch and you've been thinking about
looking for one to elevate your look or
you've been thinking about replacing the
one you have
check out vin chair oh it's an american
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing and they look like
something you'd spend a lot of money on
but ever even Cheryl watch ranges from a
hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars I went on their website and
picked out the Kyros in white and silver
really loved the look the combination of
the white face and the beige band really
loved this one they also sent me the
Kairos limited release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people I can think of in my family
anytime you see me wearing a watch on
the show I'm wearing a van share o watch
go through their collection I know
you'll find something you like and
you'll get 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch